[Music]
hello everyone
thank you very much for tuning in to
this i hope it's going to be of interest
to you
values are something that always
interested me and i think we don't take
them sufficiently
seriously and yet they are a very
important part
of our motivations as individuals and
they're also
crucial to our organizations and how we
hold together
or don't as societies so it's something
i've thought about my whole
career as an academic as a sociologist
and it's something i'm really delighted
to be talking about today and i hope
that
the what's the point the takeaway is
that what i'm saying will help you to
think
about your own values and motivations
and also about what's happening in our
in
in british society at the moment and in
organizations i'm going to talk about
how
values have become really prominent in
organizations in value statements
but how that doesn't necessarily reflect
the values that are being practiced in
those organizations
so i hope there's going to be something
that's relevant and relatable for
everybody
values can sound like something you know
pretty abstract
um but i'm going to show you that
actually um
they're very much at the heart of who we
are
and who we associate with and who we
feel friendly towards
that they're at the heart of our
organizations and groups
uh and and one of the ways in which
they're more concrete is that
we actually convey them not in you know
those abstract value statements about
these are our values
abstract and you know it's when you're
researching values
you can't really ask people what are
your values some people are very
reflective about that but of course
actually how we know is how people
behave
and the way we communicate them is in
stories uh little narratives about
what's happened to us
and at a social level in in mythologies
i don't know if any of you watched
the dares on tv last week um
on the serial killer dennis nelson those
it's really interesting and intelligent
series i loved it and
um partly because the advisor was brian
masters
the author who um
spent so much time in conversation with
nilsson
and in his book brian masters says of
nilsson that
to say he's mad or to say he's evil
doesn't really constitute an explanation
and brian master's phrase is he's as
morally mad as it's possible to be
so it was about his values and his
scrambled values that's
how masters in his book which i really
recommend
how he actually can make sense of what's
going on here
so so it's just a little example of
sprang to mind
of how values cash out and
why they really matter partly i think
why we're interested in people who
transgress our values as well because we
we can't imagine how it can be possible
and we're fascinated to see and it
helps us to see the values we do
commit ourselves to more clearly
but values aren't just an individual
thing um
our the way we behave socially is
constructed by
shared values
you can talk about values malia
societies and whole cultures you know if
you talk about
english culture scottish culture welsh
culture we're partly talking about
the stories the myths and the values
that seem common to many people
and that hold them together that's
partly what is at the heart of our
culture
and similarly in the societies the great
sociologist
emil durkheim had the insight that what
makes a society you know what defines a
society
is the fact that people come together to
affirm
shared commitment said he called them
what's sacred
and they do that and communicate those
values by holding up some
some symbol some image it might be a
flag it might be
well we'll look at lots of examples in a
minute um
that people rally around and that gives
them
emotional he called effervescence uh
he's thinking about something
well today we might be thinking about a
football match or some collective
gathering that reinforces those things
and those symbols the flag or whatever
it might be
carry carry communicate some of the
values and the feelings that they evoke
and that's what makes a society in
durkheim's view that's what holds a
society
together
at a kind of um that's looking at the
what sociologists call the meta level of
society if you look at the
the miso level kind of middle layer
where we're structured into
organizations and groups from a
religious group to to a business
organization the place you work
um and then down to micro cultures like
your family
those all have their values regimes as
well you know in a family there'll be a
a set of values
sometimes shared by some people and not
others the parents might
might adhere to certain values and try
and enforce them and of course they try
and bring their children up in them
the children might have very different
views and it might be
tensions and at the miso level
groups are held together like societies
by shared values which is why i think
organizations are coming back to this
have got so
keen on value statements and getting
people to sign up to their value
statements they think that'll make them
more cohesive
may or may not come back to them um
but it does hold us together you know
think of a school your school badge you
had a motto
um virtue and work or whatever it might
be
and there were symbols and a uniform and
all those sorts of things
all to try and cohere and every school
now if you look at every school's front
page on the web
you will find a very clear set of values
a lot of schools those now run right
through the curriculum
and are reinforced uh in in all the
lessons
so values matter and they've become much
more visible
and much more stated recently that's
part of what i want to talk about why
we've become
perhaps more is it more committed to
values or more anxious about them
let's see final sort of footnote as i'm
just setting out my terms here
um there's a very wonderful
sociologist influential sociologist of
culture called ann
swiddler and her one of her great
insights
is that culture is always an excess so
it's not
don't think that you know your culture
gives you your values you absorb them
those are the values and then you play
them out swiftly's point is that a
culture has a huge
excess of all sorts of things including
values and i think we could say that the
internet has
made that excess even more excessive
so um uh you can read that quotation
from her for yourself but it's not that
culture tells us how we behave
it gives us a repertoire of values and
we
shape our identities and decide who we
are
by selecting amongst those values and we
often select our communities
particularly um
the ones where we have a choice our
affinity groups and the online
communities
when we feel comfortable we just think
oh i feel really comfortable
with this group of people why do we feel
comfortable with them
uh we share the ethos there's something
we have in common
it's a set of values uh even if we can't
explicitly articulate what we are we
have an emotional sense
because values are not purely rational
sometimes we can articulate and spell
them out but they're just as much
embodied and emotive as durkheim was
pointing out
now i want to go on to what i'm really
wanting to do
which is to think about what values
pertain
in british society today and i am
confining myself
to um actually probably great britain i
don't think i'm even looking at northern
ireland
apologies if some of you from there um
and that's where i've done my most of my
empirical research and this is based on
that research over about 20 years which
is
a lot of national surveys that i do with
yougov as well as
field work and interview and
group work i'll explain that your story
shared storytelling is a very good way
of getting at values
so i'm going to sort of i'm going to
draw on all that material here
in trying to pick out i'm just going to
have
three three ethics three sets of values
which i think have been very influential
chronologically since the 19th century
don't mean to say they're the only ones
but i think they've they have
played a particularly important socially
cohesive role
and there's some sort of sequence
between them
so to start off with i want to talk
about what i identify
as a sacrificial ethic
the sacrificial ethic let me just first
show you this
some of you um who
have some church upbringing at school or
in family or elsewhere and that will
depend partly on your age
some of you will know this hymn it's
nearly always sung on remembrance day on
november the 11th
when there's a remembrance of those who
fell in the world wars
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai dot tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas